look I'm not here to tell you that one
decision may be good for everybody for
instance for some college is good you
know works for them so for some it's
military in turn back packing and
traveling but today I'm going to make a
case to you on why this may be an option
and I'm going to explain to three
different audiences one is the 13 14
year old kid who doesn't really know
what they want to do and they've always
kind of thought maybe military I'm I'll
give you some points on why you're gonna
have a lot of benefits to join the
military the other one's going to be an
eighteen-year-old kid now becoming an
adult you're graduating high school you
already did you're looking at possibly
military and it's the parent some of the
parents are worried about their kids
join in the military I'll make the case
12 3 and then you make the decision at
the end what you want to do because for
me I will never forget I was 14 years
old the first time I thought about
military because a guy named hey Seuss
Guerrera came up to me in Glendale and
he said hey you ought to consider
joining a military I got some options I
laughed at him I said I'll never join
the army four years later I went to him
and he recruited me so you never know
the story but I hope this makes an
impact on the way you look at military
ok so by the way if you haven't yet
subscribe to the channel please do so
and if you got any comments thoughts
questions throughout the entire episode
comment on the bottom number one reason
why I think joining the military will
give you benefits that you will not have
in college is classroom style teaching
vs. real life in in college it's a lot
of classroom somebody talks from up
there and you sit down you take notes
and you're learning to your best
abilities but we know the best way we
learn is hands-on is somebody working
there with me it's me somebody show me
here's how you do it look look how I do
it and then you do it look how I do it
anything you do it my kids go to private
school yesterday we had a parent what he
called us a parent-teacher conference
type of thing I went to last night and
one of the things they believe in which
is the reason why I like the school is
they believe kids learn more by playing
by building by doing instead of
lecturing I think College sometimes it's
way too much lecturing and there isn't
somebody getting there and showing to
them how to do it now if there is a
college you're going to that does do
that more power to them but most
colleges it's more classroom
style number two problem-solving on the
go I don't know if you learned
problem-solving undergoing college I do
know you're gonna learn it in the
military all the time I mean I can't
tell you how many times would be in you
know the back forty or we're working in
the fields and something would come up
and you don't have a long time to be
thinking about it you got to figure out
a way to solve it right there so hey
John what we going to do it - let's do
this okay Greg give me that agreement
let's grab this you have to go on the go
so it created your brain to be able to
constantly think about prom solving on
the go and by the way one of the things
you'll realize value tame and I'll talk
about one subject mainly which is
entrepreneurship and everything kind of
you know is around entrepreneurship you
will see a lot of these things that you
learn in the military will help somebody
who wants to one day run a business
number three teamwork
they don't teach you teamwork in college
honestly think about it they do not
teach your teamwork in college maybe a
couple group projects you do but there's
not really emphasises on teamwork do you
realize I would tell you everything we
did in the military was all teamwork
everything we did it from boot camp to
AIT for to being at the hunter force
Airborne Division Air Assault -
breakfast chow - running - exercising -
working - projects - everything was
teamwork everything was you have a buddy
everything was you have somebody you got
to have their back they have your back
the everything they taught you was about
teamwork and one of the things I will
tell you that's the toughest things any
CEO leader parent coach the toughest
thing anyone struggles with is to create
an environment where everybody is
working together as a team I've been
running a business for a long time and
I'm gonna tell you something here one of
the things I miss from the military when
I got out was a camaraderie of how was
to build a team and I told myself
whatever I do
wherever I work I'm always gonna bring
that to it when I worked at Bally's it
was absolute teamwork when we kicked
every other gyms bud it was teamwork
when I went into sales it was teamwork
when I was running a company it was
teamwork when it's running a family team
everything to me is stem from teamwork
College is too much about uuuuu
was about team we can do something big
together number four diversity so I'm
from Iran okay so I I joined the
military and now go to a boot camp I'm
in South Carolina and there's people
there from South Dakota North Dakota
you know Mississippi you know you got
Arkansas you got people from Oklahoma
people from Montana they have never met
a Middle Eastern before right and I
didn't know anybody from New York or
Miami or Chicago or all these other
places and you hang out together and you
learn about different diversity and you
learn about cultures you learn about
certain communities you learn about what
what's important to them what's
important to you learned so much about
diversity that yes you may pick up in
college because someone make make the
case and say well in college people go
to college from all across the countries
well in many cases from all over the
world I get it but you're in a classroom
you don't have to do anything with them
you're just in a classroom in a military
you have to work with them so you have
to get to know them because it's
teamwork so I have to get to know who
you are cuz I'm gonna work on this
project with you for three weeks I have
to know you I don't have to know you in
college I'm a party with you but I don't
have to know you we're just kind of a
classroom together number five
independence smallest thing watch this
the smallest thing is you have to wash
your own clothes you have to iron you
clothes you have to learn about starch
and crease and shining your shoes and
making sure your room is clean right you
got to mop the floor when's the last
time a teenager mopped the floor like
seven days a week you got to learn how
to clean you got you learn a lot of the
independence stuff that you have to make
decisions on your own you got to make
decisions you it's on you now there is
no more hiding behind mommy and daddy so
some of the parents that are afraid of
having their kids join the military at
the same time like I want my kids to
also be independent yes but you know
it's a little bit of this that makes a
lot of sense right you learn a lot about
of those and by the way sometimes a
teenager once I could get off my back
when they make my own decisions a little
bit a little bit for myself military may
not be a bad option for you number six
mental and emotional toughness
honestly if you ask me I was asking a
Jessica earlier I said what is the
difficult it is the opposite of a softy
you know somebody who's a softy I see a
lot of people that are soft I see a lot
of people that are too sensitive I see a
lot of people that are too emotional I
see a lot of people that are not too
stable I just see a lot of that and by
the way I'm not just talking about
Millennials Gen Xers this is a young
generation thing not at all I was a
softie and completely in high school I
was a softie the military toughened me
up mentally and emotionally I learned
what it is to be mentally tough I
learned what it is to be emotionally
tough and by the way there's a part of
it that you may go into boot camp and
realize you can't hack it and you get
out there's a part of a when you're
going you realize you can do a lot more
than you thought you could do by the way
in the business world if you are not
mentally and emotionally tough the
business world definitely ain't for you
so this could be a good wake-up call
into one day running your own business I
got a message yesterday what was a guy
on snapchat what was he Marines he's in
Marines he watches every single value
taemin video he says I'm in the Marines
right now he shows me his entire
barracks he says I watch every single
value taemin video because I cannot wait
to get out of the Marines so I can
become an entrepreneur well good for him
because he's also got the mental and the
emotional toughness from being in the
Marines number seven hands on leadership
let me take about hands on leadership oh
my gosh someone's working with you
constantly I talked about it briefly
about real life style but you have
somebody's always hands-on with you
there's a certain level of
accountability I would put seven and
eight together this is why I have it
like this number eight hands-on
leadership it demands discipline you
gotta be disciplined let me explain
first time I went to college and I went
into my classroom it was me and this
other guy named Armen by the way he runs
a business that that's 12 million
dollars a year very successful guy we go
to our class in the professor's name is
Van Damme okay what a great name by the
way English teacher Van Damme we go into
this class and he says hey I just want
you guys to know this you're officially
adults if you don't want to be in my
classroom you don't have to be my
classroom there are no role
to all the freshman's here you don't
have to be and he went through this
whole thing so I look at him I'm like
you got to be kidding me these guys are
serious I thought they were kidding that
you don't have to be in a classroom no
you don't have to be in a classroom to
bro let's get out of here
we got up we went outside we sat in
front of cafeteria place space every
single day he never went to mr. randoms
classroom a girl there would tell us
what the homework was we would do our
best and that was it but we want to play
spades and we would play spades because
there is no accountability that teacher
doesn't care if you come to classroom or
not in a military you have to come to
the classroom I mean what do you mean
you're not coming to training you're
gonna get an article 15 you have certain
responsibilities and accountability
which in some ways this teaches that to
become a habit because you always show
up sometimes this game of life is just
about showing up and sometimes college
tells you you don't have to show up if
you don't want to show up military shows
you you got to show up number 9 seeing
the world you're gonna travel and see
the world and and I can tell you for
myself when people ask me questions and
they say about how much fun I had man I
had a lot of fun in the army I mean
really I had a lot of fun in the army I
am always grateful that Instagram wasn't
around when I was in the Army you have
no idea how grateful I am that Instagram
came out after my partying days because
it'd be embarrassing some of the short
clips and pictures you would see about
my army days on how hard we partied in
the Army when we saw the world so you're
gonna see the world and you're gonna
have a good time number 10 respect your
loan respect for elders your own alone
respect for the game you'll learn
respect
it teaches respect for the opponent it
teaches respect for the enemy it teaches
respect for your competition because you
always have to be prepared if an enemy
decides to attack you there's respect
for a lot of different things right
there you'll long but that they teach
you that in the military number eleven
constantly being challenged you're
always gonna be pushed I don't care what
it is there's in a single minute that
you're not being pushed you're always
being challenged to improve number 12
you stay in shape you want to be
successful in life you got to have
energy enthusiasm you got to have
stamina if you don't have the energy you
don't stay in shape you're just not
gonna cut it in the world of business
because you got a lasts a long time
in the world of military every day
you have to exercise when you're in the
military number 13 lesser chance of
doing drugs now don't get me you know
wrong key oh you're gonna see drugs I
saw a lot of drugs one out I'm doing
guard duty and I'm going to one of my
guys as rooms
he had a mountain of nose candy on his
table and you know what nose candy is
cocaine right
he had a mountain of coke II and I'm
like I don't want to say his name I said
brother you cannot be doing all this
cocaine he says well guy named Rob gave
it to me and that woman I even knew this
other guy said I get it but you can't do
gonna go to jail month later he gets
caught he goes to military prison it's
not a way to do it so everybody saw if
you do cocaine in the military you're
gonna go to prison and you definitely
don't want to go in the middle in the
military prison right there's a lot of
accountability that if you did any of
that stuff you're losing you lose your
rank you lose everything in college if
you smoke pot do you lose a class like
you go from a sophomore to a freshman
no there is no County but no one cares
if you do drugs matter of fact do you
know a lot of people do drugs in college
military if you do there is consequences
so you work your butt off to become an
e5 or an e6 or an e4 you screw up you're
gonna go back down and that fear of
losing that people protect themselves
from not doing a drug part number
fourteen benefits you get a lot of
benefits listen it benefits is the one
health care I'll Bowl right now they
don't have the best benefits that they
take care of with the VA s but I'm gonna
tell you benefits on a different side
when I say benefits this is what I mean
I got a hired at Morgan Stanley Dean
Witter at 21 years old when I got my
serious seven and I became a broker I
got hired because the guy who hired me
man named Dave Kirby liked the fact that
I had a military background that's why
he hired me he saw my resume says you
have any college experience I said a
little bit I went to Santa Monica
Community College and Glendale Community
College but that's all I got
he says do you have a four-year or
two-year I don't it was me and another
girl who graduated in Berkeley she did a
four-year program at two and a half
years genius girl says but you were in a
military right they teach you discipline
and hard work in a military yes I like
that you'll have the job as well
both of us were hired she was college I
was military we both were hired
the benefits on the resume being in the
military helps you to do a lot of other
things in your career
I like when I'm hiring somebody if they
have military background I know their
skin is thick they're not soft they're
not the weak they're willing to work
hard they're disciplined they know what
it is to work like a team I know that so
I like that on resumes and I like
working matter of fact the top earners
that I work with the best salespeople in
our company
he has military experience he was in the
Marines for eight years he did three
tours in Afghanistan all these other
places he's tough he's great at bringing
everybody together I like that part
right I don't have to call this person
out knowing he's gonna get sensitive
upset at me because he comes from that
world then you have college paid for
it's crazy you go to if you go to a if
you go to college you don't necessarily
learn discipline but if you go to
military you can go to college at the
same time there was a lot of guys that
weren't in the unit with me you know
military endorses you to go to college
they want you to go to college you don't
mind if you have class rooms at night
there was a lot of guys that got their
four-year degrees when they were in
there for four years as well at the same
time so you can get your bachelor's when
you're in there get all these other
benefits and still get your college
degree while you're in the military
they're gonna give you scholarships for
that as well and last but not least is
the obvious one you're gonna work hard
you will definitely work hard I mean I
can tell you I never thought I could
work 36 hours straight until I did are
you gonna without coffee without
anything just water you're gonna work
hard you're gonna push that limit where
you hit and when you hit that limit you
know what you start realizing afterwards
when you go to another company or
wherever you want to move up in a
company there's one thing you're not
afraid of you are not afraid of out
working anybody because nothing's gonna
be more work than the more food in the
military nothing is there's not a single
job you'll ever do that'll be more work
than a military it's just not going to
be not going to be so that'll give you
an edge of all in the military of
learning how to work hard so these are
16 points by the way somebody can come
into video and saying 16 reasons why you
ought to join the college instead of
military and they can give their
arguments and there probably is going to
be some valid arguments there as well
but I'm just telling you right now I
would say for every 20 that goes to
college only a couple go to the military
there's a lot of benefits of getting
involved in the military so if you have
any questions thoughts comments comment
on the bottom and if you haven't yet
subscribe to this channel click here to
subscribe to the channel take
everybody's go bye
[Music]